- [Instructor] We're
already somewhat familiar
with the idea of division.
If I were to say eight divided by two
you could think of that as eight objects.
So one, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven, eight
divided into equal groups of two.
And so how many equal groups
of two could you have?
Well you could have one,
two,
three,
or four groups of two
and so you'd say eight divided
by two is equal to four.
Another way we could've thought about that
is you have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight
and if you were to divide
it into two equal groups
well you could have one group of four.
Let me get a little bit cleaner.
One group of four and then
a second group of four.
So two equal groups.
How many in each of those equal groups?
Well they're four in each of those groups.
And so once again eight divided
by two is equal to four.
Now we're going to extend
our knowledge of division
by starting to think about
things that don't divide evenly.
So what if we were to say
what is
eight divided by three?
Pause this video
and see if you can think
about that a little bit.
All right so let's draw
eight objects again.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight
and one way to think about it
is how we thought about it here
is can we divide this into groups
that all have three in them
and how many groups would
we be able to make of three?
Well let's try it out.
I can make this group of three,
I can make this second group of three
but I can't make any more group of three
and what I have left over are these two.
And so the way that
you would describe this
or one way to describe this is
hey I was able to make two group of three
so it's equal to two
and there's some left over,
there's a remainder.
Let me write that down.
Important concept.
There is a remainder of two as well
and so sometimes it's
written as just a lowercase r
or remainder of two.
Another way to think about it is
two, this two times three is six
and then if you were to
put back that remainder
that's how you can get to eight.
Now another way you can think about it
is how we thought about
it in the second example
with eight divided by two.
Let me draw eight objects again.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight
and you could say hey
let me divide that eight
into three equal groups.
So pause this video and
see if you can divide this
into three equal groups
and then what might be left over.
All right, so I'm going to try
to divide this into three equal groups.
I'm not going to be able to put
four in each of those groups
'cause I can only make
two equal groups of four.
I'm not going to be able
to put three into those,
three equal groups
'cause I would actually be
outing nine for doing that
so each of my groups are
going to have to be two.
So I could make one group of two,
another group of two,
and there you go three
equal groups of two.
So I was able to sort out
three equal groups of two
with just these six
but once again I have a remainder.
I'm not able to make use of these two,
they're not able to fit into one of
in this case one of
the three equal groups.
If I said four equal groups
then they would fit in,
but if I just said three equal groups
'cause I'm dividing by three
then I have this left over again.
Let's do one more example.
What if I were to ask you what is,
what is
divided by
four?
Pause this video and think about it
and as you might imagine
there will be a remainder involved.
All right, well let's draw 13 objects,
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight
nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen
and we could try to divide
this into equal groups of four,
that's one way to think
about it so let's see.
That's a group of four,
I have one group of four.
I have two groups of four
and then that is a group of four
so I'm able to find three
equal groups of four
so this is equal to three.
Another way to think about it
four goes into 13 three times
but then I have this
little lonely circle here,
I have one left over
I have a remainder of one
because four times three
that gets you to 12
but then if you wanna get to 13
well then you gotta throw
in that remainder there.